right uh
thanks for the organizers first for
organizing this uh wonderful workshop uh
it's been a pleasure to be here
and uh so today i'm going to talk about
this uh
um series of results that we had about
how to use functional approximation like
how you can use functional approximation
engineering reinforcement learning
uh was the utility of having functional
approximation in reinforcement learning
and all that
and
so
first i
want to thank my collaborators uh it is
gallart he's discovering that this was
embodied from above and you can see the
joy on his face uh for seeing this
and uh he's a a deep mind and he's also
a phd student at ucl
and uh other collaborators being uh
philip uh who is a peer student with
none
um none is also there and bonobosciencer
who is a phd student in cambridge yassin
and andrash are at the foundations team
at deepmind
okay
so i'm going to start by going back to
the year of 1963
probably not
at the time i wasn't
uh so i don't remember i don't have
direct memories but uh it was a
fantastic year because this paper was
published
not here
really knows about this paper but
it's kind of interesting uh
to go back to these all papers this is a
paper by richard baumann robert calaba
and bella kotkin
and the type that is polynomial
approximation a new computational
technique in dynamic programming
allocation process so i want to use this
paper as a precursor to explain to you
what this function approximation
business in reinforcement learning is
about
and uh it's kind of oh my animations are
down
all right anyways um
never mind uh so it solves a um what
they call an allocation process it's a
very specific instance of uh you can
cast at stand dp usc that it's uh it's
tested effectively as an mdp
and so what is this you're given a
age
different
utility functions
and they correspond to each different
projects
that you want to allocate
uh resources in between the resources
are d dimensional
and a resource lives in this
in this hypercube in this two
dimensional hypercube so you want to
split up
your
total amount of resources
into edge different parts
such that you're maximizes the you're
maximizing the total utility how do you
do this
i think programming was invented for
doing things like this
uh so you can imagine picturing that
these are the non-linear utility
functions
and you are at some stage age and you're
trying to make a decision about uh what
to do there and so far you decided to
allocate
this much of the resources has
so this is one dimension and also that i
can throw it
and uh
as as you go um
you can imagine that from this point on
things are going to go on optimally
so you can define the optimal value
achievable in the remaining period so
for the remaining
projects
given that you have already used up this
much resources and uh it's not hard to
see and this was kind of like the thing
that that richard baumann uh
was
actually exploiting in many different
ways
that
these optimal value functions satisfy
this recursion right
so the uh the optimal value function for
some stage is a function of the optimal
very function of the next stage we just
have to think about that okay how is the
optimal value for this stage well i need
to make a decision for this stage for
the remaining resources so i have to
subtract from the resources i have but
i've already spent
and so this is uh the interval where
where i can make a decision for that i'm
going to get a payoff for this uh for
this project
and
i will also consume some resources and i
i will end up somebody else and i will
continue optimally from that point on so
uh because of the additive structure uh
the optimal value is going to be the sum
over these two things uh and and you
just have to choose the best uh best
action for that
for this stage
and you have a a
boundary condition uh for the for the
final stage as well and and the question
that they are asking this paper is how
to compute uh optimal value and and
specifically what is the allocation
it's a very simple problem
and uh
this looks beautiful uh
and they're thinking about like they
were trying to solve this for specific
cases when there is some extra structure
but they saw that like that doesn't
quite generalize very bad so they turned
to numerical solutions so they were
thinking previously about discretizing
basically this state space discretizing
the action space but then they notice
that well if you discretize a d
dimensional space you want to have some
good accuracy
then your research needs for computing
this thing are going to blow up
exponentially with dimension
so the question is
can we do something about this and so
this is what this paper was about in
1963
so what they propose is very simple
so uh go back to the one-dimensional
case uh maybe the the state business
just this minus one for me very well
change it a little bit
uh and um you can imagine that you will
have some basis functions so so they are
thinking about you know orthogonal basis
functions of various kinds
and
you are going to linearly combine these
basis functions to represent the optimal
value function in approximate manner
and then somehow you plug this in into
the recursion that we had before
so what does this do so what what's
what's the the new idea here the new
idea is that we are well okay like this
shouldn't be b uh that's that's a
different d uh so uh the new idea is
that we are decoupling the
dimensionality of the state space
from how many basis functions we are
using and if you have a good guess about
kind of the smoothness of the optimal
value function or what basis functions
are going to capture the optimal value
function well
then maybe you can uh get away
with just using a few coefficients and
all that you'll have to do is to to
discover these coefficients for okay you
have to do it for every stage but
but that's the the only thing that you
have to do
and so that's indeed what they propose
and and they have so we have this
recursion and they call these successive
approximations you can write it with
operator notation as well and then they
just have this idea that but we just
have to plug in these basis functions
and somehow calculate the coefficients
and and uh
then the question is okay if i have
coefficients for the next stage how do i
get coefficients for the for the current
stage and specifically what they propose
is that well you just do these
calculations in some way uh this uh
the successive approximations at some
notes at some points
and then you extrapolate or interpolate
you you just saw the
function fitting
so this function fitting is going to
basically project this function into the
span of the features so that's what they
propose and today we would recognize
this is an instance of fitted value
iteration so in in reinforcement
learning this is what what
people call fitted by iteration
so they they use this uh
i don't know ottoman not non-basis and
gaussian quadratures for approximating
the projection because uh they're over
45 for this job we would just use monte
carlo
all right so what are the results any
good paper has to have some some
numerical results
uh they had two dimensional problems
they were very happy they calculated
like they have nice tables and they
conclude that if they combine these
techniques polynomial approximations
language multipliers come in because you
have constrained action set uh with that
of successive approximations there
should be very few allocation processes
which still resistor so they're kind of
ambitious by modest at the same time
right like all location processes but
it's
there is there is definitely optimism
there um all right
so by the optimism it's because
they kind of think that they figure out
how to avoid this conservation
so
no curse of dimensionality so it's obama
on calling this term curse of
dimensionality due to the decision that
they were
really not a fan of that
okay so there are two questions that
arise
and the first question that arises
is the question that i defend to our
colleagues in the economic econometrics
and and other departments uh so that's
the question of like how to choose this
modern mast uh or how to choose the
basis functions
to approximate the optimal life function
and
i rather want to focus just on on the
computational aspect of the problem
which is that if someone already chose
some basis functions
can we really use these basis functions
uh to get these coefficients and and get
the optimal very good approximation to
the optimal value or get get a good
policy benefit
in particular um so
we're gonna have mvps they're finitely
many actions so that that's going to be
a simplification compared to what
they're doing
so a is a number of actions age is going
to be number of projects a number of uh
time steps horizon uh these the number
of features and and some accuracy uh
epsilon that that we desire and we ask
the question are there algorithms out
there they are able to deliver this
accuracy um
regardless of the size of the state
that's
space
question
all right any questions
okay so the problem is clear good so we
are done
with the first two parts
um
just
one slide with some notation uh and some
terminology because well i i will need
to to rely on
some some of this uh
so we're gonna
be more ambitious look at mdps uh
it's not our location processes but it's
it's a very close relative we're gonna
have states
so we have the bam and optimality
acquisition as before we're gonna have
states we have actions they're in a
feasible set but i'm going to simplify
in a feasible set is always going to be
the full action set don't think that uh
at this moment uh that simplification is
i think tolerable
uh for every uh stage and every state in
action uh if you take that action in
that state you receive an immediate
reward of r
and then you transition to an a next
state which is random next state so
there is some randomness uh acting on
the transition so this is a transition
function
and uh then the optimality equation
looks like this and uh so one uh
little innovation that uh well okay it's
actually quite quite a nice thing that
that comes from the machine learning
literature chris watkins innovation is
that by this right hand side if we just
add these two things together
you can call it the actual value
of choosing action a in this state
and uh sometimes it's very beneficial to
directly approximate the actual value
function why because if i knew the
actual value function i would know how
to act optimally
the yes assumption for all value
functions or just the optional one uh
we'll come to that there will be a whole
discussion about this yeah so this is
just for for now not tissue um this is
clear
right so one more notation is that uh so
i'm going to drop this notation mo for
most of the time uh in the mdp
literature and machine learning you
usually have just a transition cut off
and my notation is going to be that like
if you have a state s and an action a
then this is just a probability
distribution over the next state so i
can write something like the in that
product of this probability distribution
you suspect this is a value function
that gives you the expected value that
you're gonna get if you transition
according okay
so just to so that i can
simply find some notation
all right um
so
yeah back to the contents uh so we are
done with this first two things and
um
i told you in a panel you have to
concentrate an argument so i'm going to
focus on some arguments uh
so i will talk about optimistic
constraint propagation uh
which is an argument by jian bang and
ben monroy from 2013
uh which is addressing this problem um
in the deterministic setting
and
then i'm going to talk about a bunch of
other algorithms
under misspecification and then i will
talk about
uh results that that
i call weak functional approximation
results and that's going to be the back
of the target
right we're done with this uh so the
first uh part is this optimistic
constraint propagation algorithm this is
for deterministic algorithms
uh sorry deterministic mdps
um so we have these basis functions
and we want to figure out uh what the
coefficient is the coefficient is shared
between all the stages without loss of
charity
and
if
you
if if you make this assumption
then you can plug in
your uh
your function approximator into the bam
and equation
you can subtract one side from the other
and i know it becomes a root finding
problem so you just want to find this
theta parameter
that makes what we call the td error to
be zero
at all the state action pairs so we have
a bunch of constraints
if we find the right
constraints maybe you can just find
these equations uh sorry find find the
root for these equations so the td
uh should be zero at all the stages and
and all the the the transitions um
and um so we're going to focus on on
trying to uh
to
to shrink the parameter space
so initially we are ignorant we don't
know uh
the solution
all the t-tests are possible so what
we're going to do is that we're going to
start with all possible parameters so we
assume that the true parameter has a
known element bond b it lies in this
version space
and we're going to iterate
and in every iteration uh
of the argatum
the first step we're going to choose uh
an optimistic
parameter so what is the optimistic
parameter it's like definition of
optimistic parameter is that like this
parameter was true parameter we would
get the highest value at the initial
state
there's some initial state we are
running
we're going to run experiments from
there so it's like online already
and then
once you have this parameter you can
just like do as if this was the true
parameters this is going to be
verification we are going to
generate a bunch of new constraints so
we roll out with the resulting policy up
to the end of the trajectory
we collect all the data that uh so we
collect basically a trajectory it's
deterministic so there is only one
trajectory
up to the end
and then you can measure these td errors
along the trajectory
and you're going to enlarge your
constraint set by adding
uh
the constraints that all these td errors
need to be
along the trajectory
so you think the potentially thing that
you check uh shrink the the version
space
and you're gonna stop when you cannot
shrink anymore
so if you ever find
a trajectory such that
you're not shrinking the version space
then you stop well you need to ask the
question is this computationally
efficient uh
yes you can implement this
computationally efficiently
and the other question is is this going
to really work is this going to return
an optimal uh
action and uh so that that's that's the
genius of these two gentlemen uh they
show that it is and uh i will later show
you an argument that generalizes this
algorithm and i will explain a little
bit more at that algorithm about like
why this argument works okay and then
you will understand okay
clearly if these other aggregate
universities must work
yes i was on board
um
i see that you need maybe a little bit
more so this is just online right so i
only need to
have the ability to execute trajectories
but the initial state is random uh
then i think it's it's a little bit more
delicate like you will need to add
extra stuff but you can accept it
i missed the beginning so uh is this
equality the first one the quality
function is c times let's start is that
an assumption or without loss of zero
no that was the assumption so that is
what baman told us that we have these
basis functions and then you just need
to find the coefficients and then we are
asking a question can we find the
coefficients yeah absolutely good
question
all right
okay
all right so so they proved this theorem
that for any
of these different systems blah blah
this algorithm stops and and its body
time and body number of uh queries uh
are uh sent to the environment
right this this is great uh
uh so this was by the way like 50 years
after bama's original paper uh there's
been a lot of other developments but
somehow
like this question was not really
thoroughly looked at
and even uh in the interim period
people were busy with other things but
eight years later
uh this paper by dukaka devon and young
appeared and that inspired us among
others
and
this then sparked a number of other
results and so now uh basically uh i
want to tell you about all these
exciting developments that happened
since then
all right
so the setup of this dukaka devon young
paper uh it has a lot of different
results it is basically the the paper
that starts to ask these computational
questions and query efficiency questions
in a very clear language so it's it's uh
that that's a big contribution of this
paper
and uh so one of the setups that they
look at
is that uh you can um
if you have a policy
for each policy that is also an action
value function that describes how much
this policy is going to make
if you start it in the state and you
take an action and then you follow the
place okay so that's the actual value
function of the policy
and one of the setups in the paper is
that they assume that
for all the policies the action value
function lies in the span of the
features
up to an error of epsilon so that's the
approximation error and it's a uniform
approximation error
and the genius of this is that they they
start to ask a question like even if
like we have this much stronger
assumption
oh sorry much
so it's strong and weak at the same time
it's a strong assumption
because no for every actual value
function
for every policy we assume that the
features are good
so the feature is good for many
different things
but there is some residual error so
there is this epsilon uniform
approximation error
so there is a question
under this setting
is it possible or not
to come up with a query efficient
algorithm an algorithm that would you
like just go in in the mdp
and there are different query models so
here that they consider the generic
model or
i call it random access model or global
random access where you can poke any
steel action pair and get a transition
from there and get corresponding reward
the other question is this possible and
then they prove that uh this is this is
not going to work so if you have a
target accuracy of delta and this target
accuracy is uh
is not low enough
uh sorry it is not high enough so if the
target accuracy was like compared to the
approximation error is inflated by a
factor of square root of d
then you may have a chance of having a
polynomial
but if this is not the case then you
have no chance
so this kind of like a big wake-up call
for everyone who was hoping for for
something much better
because it seems that well on the one
hand we have uniform approximation
errors
so there's like l infinite errors
they're already big
and now if you're not inflating those by
a factor of spelt of d at least
then there is no hope
for
a computationally efficient solution
because there is no query efficient
solution
uh either
right so so this was a
very um
kind of
uh innovative uh at the time
and uh you you can pair this with a
positive result that says that well okay
if if your target accuracy is exceeding
uh this critical threshold then
polynomial computation is is available
and that's what we were doing in our
paper because
to have both sides
and so so what's the insight here so the
insight is that
uh in reinforcement learning
you really need or or in this mdp
calculations you really need to deal
with uniform approximation errors
because uh
you're looking at like maximum values
the optimal values and some of the they
pair much better uh like they kind of
force you in into this
uh
uh just working with uniform
approximation errors and these uniform
approximation errors if you are only
making so many measurements of a
function
that is just nearly realizable
then they can blow up so
extrapolating from
polynomial many queries
without blowing up the approximation
error by a factor of square root of d is
just information typically not possible
sometimes
so caveat is that this is not this is
specific to some choice of uh the basis
functions or this feature map as we call
it uh in machine learning
so you can choose much friendlier ones
but there is no blowout
okay so that's an interesting
direction maybe to to try to understand
what's what's happening there and so now
back to you to emma's question so what
what are the assumptions that we are
making uh
so
there are a bunch of assumptions like uh
that you could make like like this one
that i talked about that all the uh all
policies actually functions lie in your
function space
or you could make an alternative one
which says that under the bam an
optimality operator this function space
that's induced by the the feature so the
basis functions is closed so there are
these assumptions concerning the
features i call them the strong
assumptions right because know the
features uh have to do a lot for us we
are asking them to do a lot
the weak assumption is uh what i think
belmont and and and these other people
in the early days had in their mind that
uh it's only the optimal value function
or the optimal action value function
lies in the span of the features
so there are uh
these two alternate ways of thinking but
here we already saw that if you add
approximation errors then unless you're
willing to explode those approximation
errors by this uh square root factor or
something that depends on the features
there is no hope for uh query efficient
algorithms
so
um
that is the question of like okay here
we are
assuming even less uh can it work well
the the errors need to be uh blown up or
uh if if you're interested in negative
results uh or like we think that maybe
the reasons are not going to be positive
then you can ask the question okay what
if you have exact realizability so that
is the the value function lies
in the span of the features like can we
do it so that's the question that we're
going to look at
next
so you know in a way this is more
ambitious but uh but there is usually no
mis-specification if there was some
specification you can tolerate it but
like the errors blow up
how pathological are those lower bound
instances of the
that's pretty pathological
yeah
yeah it's like the the lower bond
instance on the previous slide it's just
like a big tree and like
uh it's it relies on constructing the
features uh it's basically packing the
the unit sphere with the feature vectors
uh
and and that that creates this this uh
this blew up of the errors
um if you have uh friendlier features
then then don't expect this problem that
that result is really about the blowout
that this blow up in the worst case is
necessary
um okay
um but but you can you can ask the same
questions for the the coming negative
designs too
yeah that baby
yeah well i think that they are
insightful white pathological
um all right so we are done with this uh
and so let's let's get to uh results
about this weak function approximation
all right uh so as you're gonna see uh
the single most important determining
factor in this results is going to be
how big is your actual space
the action space could be relative to
the num
the number of stages in the problem
and the the number of uh features or
basis functions
it could be you know like polynomial or
much less like constant
or much more
exponential in the smallest of the two
and we're gonna see that
this determines a lot
so i will call this first two cases the
few action skills and and this one is
just fun so let's start with the uh many
actions case we have already seen this
result so we're going to build these
tables uh so they're all these like you
can choose this you can choose that and
like you're going to have a lot of fun
building these tables
so we have seen this result this is the
the mentioned ben one reuters ad from
2013 and just to explain the notations
so the optimal parameter vector uh lies
in this uh
ball of radius b
uh these the number of features it is
the horizon is the number of actions and
the number of features is assumed to be
bonded by one
and the uh in the tables we're going to
have
source like how many actions we have
what is the mdp class so explain this
notation uh
so m is for mvp uh these are the
parameters uh this q star means that
it's q sterilizable so that means that
the features are such that that are
handed to the algorithm that the q star
function this optimal action value
function lies in the span of the
features and this intersection is uh
just means that by this this other class
this is all deterministic mdps
so
if you consider only deterministic mdps
and the q star function is realizable
then this check mark means that there is
a
poly query complexity and in this case
also computational complexity argument
that solves this problem
so that's the first result uh so the
next result is is um
from a paper of course uh that says that
if you have a large number of actions
exponential in the smallest of uh the
dimension and and the horizon
and you give up on deterministic and the
peace
then this nice result is gone
and this is also going to be uh based on
some pathological construction if you
want uh
and uh so that's that's pretty sad
but um
okay so uh one more one more thing
so this global access it just means this
charity model so it's like uh you're
interacting with a simulator and then
you actually know what the state space
is it's like a pretty strong condition
uh because when you have you know a
simulator of a robot like what do you
know like which states are legal or how
to call even the states so that's a
pretty strong assumption but for a
negative result uh we want to have a
strong assumption right so even if the
simulator has global axis
uh the transitions piece transition the
transition kernel
can be deterministic
but the reverse can be stochastic
so it's enough to to make the rewards uh
stochastic
of course you can push it to the other
side all right
um and now uh
here is a shock uh so if you have any
number of actions
and you have both v star and q
sterilizability
and
you have global access
no you can do it
so uh
so that that's that's pretty interesting
that's quite surprising that's very
efficient uh it's not computationally
efficient
it basically that algorithm needs to
kind of like read the whole state space
do a bunch of calculation it's doing
this version space pruning it's like
pretty aggressive
and it really needs this global access
we will see it on the next slide
right um
so
i already talked a little bit about
these simulator access models but but i
just want to clarify it a little bit
more so we talked about this global
access uh
the algorithm gets a description of the
fluid state space
uh it gets all the features of all the
states up front it can do any
computation with it and then some of
these algorithms
in quotation mark do this
and can ask for a transition at any
state actually
local access model i'm going to talk
about local access next uh it doesn't
get the description of the full estate
space it's it's much more realistic uh
only gets the features associated with
states that are being visited
simulation simulation always starts at
some initial state that you can get back
to
and
the simulator
can be reset to a previously visited
state so there is checkpointing in the
simulator if you want so you can
implement this by having a simulator and
then like as you go like you as a
simulator to save it in internal state
and then later on you say well
step number 152 when whatever state you
were at like let's go back there because
it was interesting so that's what you
can do with local access um
you said your result was not efficient
in a global access model but what does
efficient mean in the global access
yeah i mean like uh it could be that it
doesn't use global access that way right
the argument could choose not to use
this all this part
uh
yeah
okay and and finally uh the uh the
weakest of all of these assumptions
online access which is like when you're
interacting with the real environment
that's like what you have you can't
reset back to previously visited states
if you have deterministic transitions of
course you could do that by saving how
you got to some state
but if you have stochastic transitions
then that's not possible so again like
we kind of see
the difference between stochastic and
deterministic environments um
just kind of interesting
okay so
the few action scales uh
so uh if you have only a constant number
of actions then we have lots of check
marks here
so let me go through this rules one by
one so there is v star realizability
or uh and under that you can get
positive result there is q star
realizability but the transition should
be deterministic
the rewards can be stochastic now and
that's that's kind of like if your
initial state is also stochastic you
kind of like fold it into here
uh
then uh you can you can do it and if you
have v star and q style
uh realizability simultaneously you have
two feature sets so on the previous
slide this like if you have visa and q
star realizability kind of work hand in
hand you have two feature sets and two
set of business functions but this only
holds
under the states that are reachable from
the initial state
uh so that's uh
that's that's the a distinctly
weaker condition it turns out
that uh then assuming that we start q
star are realizable at all the states
and uh so under this this uh this result
uh also holds
uh on the local axis
and no if you increase the action count
you say promise the actions uh action
count determines everything here uh to
be lower the polynomial of the minimum
of uh the dimension and and the horizon
then you get negative results uh
pretty much for all the cases so you can
start with we stylize a bit then you can
slash in determinism there it doesn't
have
uh q sterilizability
you you got the negative result and we
start q star reachable realizability
deterministic transitions you get a
negative result so notice that like in
the previous slide we had this positive
result on the global axis for the same
set or like for the for the uh under the
strong stronger assumption that v star
and q star are realizable at everywhere
yeah
all right
okay so i i actually want to start with
with the green rows uh
why these problems are not hard
uh i'm just going to talk about this
setting and then you can generalize this
setting to the other side
i've done that
so we have constant number of actions we
have stochastic transitions we start
realizability and local access so the
algorithm is is going to be called
tester plan
and it turns out that this is kind of
like just
a slight modification of this constraint
propagation algorithm
of
junk ban and and ben monroy
so we have the same notation uh except
that now we have uh not action value
functions but statewide functions
you have the td editor
which is the difference between you know
uh
like how much reward you're gonna you're
predicting to make uh under this uh
theta parameter that is how much reward
you're making
and uh so this is the new thing so uh
rather than
saying that well i would need to know
like remember in the td error previously
there was a maximum of reactions
an optimistic constant propagation area
there is no maximum reactions here
but what we are doing is that we are
taking taking the td errors
and we are multiplying them all
so these td adders are just like numbers
right
if any of them was zero then the product
is going to be zero and the product is
only going to be zero if one of them is
there right like it's it's pretty
automatic so you can basically rewrite
the baman equation
by
saying that under this condition
uh
the product of the td errors at all the
state action pairs
is going to be zero
right because if you take the optimal
action
that optimal policy gives you
that makes the td error zero so that
that's that's one direction and the in
the other direction if you have this
well it doesn't that doesn't quite imply
that you have the optimal
um
that doesn't quite imply that you have
the optimal policy including that there
is some other policy
for which this equation is hard but
we're gonna fix that so there's no
problem
all right um
and uh later on it will be clear by its
advantages to get rid of the maximum and
and write this product
so how does the algorithm work it's
basically copy pasting the the previous
algorithm uh we start with the full uh
parameter set we are iterating we are
going to be optimistically choosing a
parameter vector
and after that we do a rollout
we don't do one rollout because we have
stochastic transitions so we do a bunch
of sufficiently high number of rollouts
uh we collect the trajectories
and along the trajectories we're going
to measure approximately the td errors
by using our local access to the
simulator so if you're in a trajectory
you were choosing a state action pair
you need to measure the uh the td error
there what is a td error so there is
this uh averaging happening there so
you're gonna use your simulator we set
to the state action pair a number of
times and then you approximate quite
closely the td adder so that we are
using very very strongly the local
access model
that you're able to do that in the
online access model where you can only
run trajectories it would be really hard
to get back to exactly the same state
actually so it's a strong use of of
simulators and once you you did that uh
you're shrinking uh the parameter space
and uh
return if the parameter space uh didn't
change or
it's in the actual algorithm it's
slightly more complicated
you seem to have made a sort of careful
choice to approximate the value function
and also use a q function like
that's right
yeah
is there a
some insight into why or well it's
because we want to get rid of the max
so
the max is is not playing valve it's all
the linearity in everything and and we
are going to see that the product plays
much better with linearity
in the cube we would have a max yeah
and that's why we can only deal with
this deterministic transitions uh when
you have q starters
all right um
so
questions uh so why would a teaser plan
uh the desired term stop changing uh
parameter vector
uh
well uh
so
if you look at so why why is this
product
a b
compared to using a max
if you look at what this product means
you you can write it out as an
interproductory order determines
introduce these tensor products
and then what you're going to see is
that this can be viewed
as a linear
uh constraint
on the polynomial of the parameter
vector right it the stanza product of
the parameter
and so this is a bunch of linear
constraints
and so that was why what was advantages
because we can solve linear uh
problems or we know like for how long uh
you can
just add constraints and
and uh eventually uh find the solution
uh when when you're
exhausting uh all the dimensions right
so after you adding uh d plus one over a
constraints uh
then you
shrunk the parameter set and and you
found the solution
so that's why we are switching from the
max uh to the product
and so the the other question is what
was the rule of optimism here
and i already uh gave you a hint uh
that uh
the the algebraic biomechanization
doesn't go both ways like that there
could be policies
for which the algebraic biomedication
boards which are not optimal policies
and uh the way to get out of this and
you you want you want policies which
have high value
so a natural choice then is just to be
optimistic with respect to the
initial state because when that happens
when when that happens
uh
then you can guarantee that the policy
whenever you're stopping the policy
that you're going to get if you haven't
eliminated the optimal uh policy is
going to be optimal
i have two minutes left
so this is uh the result that you can
prove and uh so back to emma's question
uh so what's the insight about like why
the action set has such a huge influence
uh we were doing this sensorization this
algebraic trick because of that d to the
power of a appears and you can predict
from that that things are not going to
go well if the number of actions is
going to be higher now the question is
is that really true so that's another
paper
i i won't have time to to explain it
it's it's basically an information
critic argument that
somehow
uh having already polynomially many
actions uh in an each horizon problem is
is going to throw off all the arguments
like you can you can hide rewards
and uh and no algorithm is is
information to be able to to find them
all right so um
so one one a slight note about this is
that in bandits this is totally not true
so you can have larger extreme spaces
you have a horizon of one
and uh
this disregarding computational problems
you can solve all oil on right problems
right like near bandits is an awesome
topic
regardless of the number of actions you
can have infinite
anyway so so this is the full table uh
um and then there is a question of
whether you can get uh this is just
credit gray efficiency uh so when when
can you do it computationally
efficiently
we know that in this case you could do
it and then uh you took you should talk
to to grove i don't know where he's uh
he's not at the moment here but he's
staying at simon's uh
and um
yeah he's been working on this problem
we've been working on this problem and
in short uh
we are there are already uh some results
by them uh published that called this
year
that show that under some conditions
some of these problems cannot be solved
computationally efficiently
and
the prediction is that well
unfortunately uh
this is going to be true for the
remaining problems
okay
all right uh so
wrapping up uh so baman's uh
modest optimism did it hold up
well uh as far as successive
approximations are concerned it seems
that when the algorithms can do
something they're not really doing that
so that's kind of like a very
interesting uh point to me uh if you try
to do this successive approximation type
of algorithms that they they were
introducing
they incur a lot more errors so they're
blowing up errors uh
way faster than this version space
shrinking algorithms
yet
if you think about computational
efficiency it seems that they're onto
something because
uh
the vaginal space think uh
shrinking algorithms can only work in in
very specific cases and in all the other
cases it's more like a dp solution that
that we are having um and another big
conclusion is that even if you have
strong functional approximation you will
have to leave this uh
uh approximation error blow up due to
expiration
uh unlike in bandits large action spaces
are going to be a nightmare
um and i have a bunch of open problems
but i just stopped here
all right
like one question
could you say a little bit about the
open products
yeah
uh so yeah it's it's given given
everything that was built up uh it's
fairly easy to state
them uh
so we don't know whether the very
complexity can be kept uh
in this case when you have pure
sterilization and you have constant
number of actions and the transitions
are stochastic we only know there's a
positive answer for deterministic
transitions for stochastic transitions
just to leave with us
you have no idea it's
very intriguing the next one
is what is the competition complexity
when you have constant number of actions
then you have these type 2 stylization
globally
and
the next one is that if you have online
access
so you don't have uh this coupon under
queue finalizability
if we had global access or we have a
newer paper that say that if you have
local access
then you can get every single amount of
time and like it's beautiful
but we don't have the same uh result for
online access which is kind of the real
deal if you're interacting with real
environments maybe there is a separation
between when you're interacting with the
simulator even if it's just provides you
local access it could be
that you can solve some of these
problems and consult them if you only
have online access
and then like there are later open
questions uh
like how to deal with this
non-functional approximation
and balance paper uh obviously was
considering continuous actual spaces you
know there was a lot of other structure
there but
uh
clearly from this work if if the number
of actions exploding in worst case like
not something can be said but that can't
be the end right
right and then uh it seems deterministic
dynamics is helpful
you can do things with this
factorization
i don't know like these are these are
bigger open questions the first few are
nice enough
thank you
[Applause]
back here 15.